remaniement ministériel à québec débat
bien sûr sur les oléoducs à ottawa deux
sujets qui ont beaucoup retenu
l'attention au cours de la semaine si
bien que inévitablement d'autres
nouvelles sont passées sous le radar
j'en discute donc avec marie hélène
tremblay yves mano de nos bureaux
parlementaire de québec et ottawa
mon dimanche marie hélène à québec
d'abord le remaniement ministériel a
chambardé le calendrier des travaux de
plusieurs commissions dont celle sur la
réforme des commissions scolaires mais
en le d'autres aussi qui sont passés
inaperçus
effectivement il ya les travaux prévus
pour la commission parlementaire qui va
revoir la loi sur l'immigration qui
finalement n'a siégé que quelques heures
les travaux qui étaient prévus jeudi et
vendredi ont été annulés à cause
justement de ce remaniement ministériel
mais chose certaine c'est une réforme en
profondeur qui s'amorce au niveau de
cette loi sur l'immigration alors c'est
en quelque sorte emmanuel la fin du
régime premier arrivé premier servi
un système qui a contribué selon la
ministre de l'immigration a engorgé en
quelque sorte le système
alors dorénavant se conçoit de fer seuil
à l'est par la déclaration d'intérêts
choisir les immigrants en fonction des
profils justement ceux des besoins dans
les régions du québec mais aussi en
fonction et l'adapter surtout en
fonction du marché du travail c'est un
changement important
les partis d'opposition adhère justement
à cette orientation du gouvernement
couillard alors maintenant où il risque
cependant d'y avoir un accrochage je
sais chose certaine ça concerne la
pérennité de la langue française la
ministre kathleen weil l'a dit dans son
allocution d'ouverture que le projet de
loi aura pour effet de préserver la
vitalité la langue française
les partis d'opposition autant la carte
que le parti québécois ne sont pas
d'accord avec cette affirmation
il pense qu'il faudra dix ans durcir un
peu le temps au niveau du projet de loi
changer certains articles parce que
justement la langue ne sera pas protégé
alors ce serait intéressant de voir ce
qui va se passer il y aura évidemment un
nouveau calendrier parlementaire qui va
être établi pour ce qui est des travaux
de la commission
il ya une quarantaine de groupes qui
seront entendues alors chose certaine
il y aura sûrement des accrochages au
niveau de la langue française ce sera
intéressant de suivre ce qui va se
passer là bas parce qu'on soit ni plus
ni moins que le régime entre en place
l'an prochain en 2017
voilà si rapidement alors je sais que
vous allez garder un oeil là-dessus au
cours des prochaines semaines
yves de votre côté le gouvernement
trudeau lui exauce une promesse
électorale en vérité à broche de loi
fédérale qui avait été adoptée par les
conservateurs de loi là qu'on décrivait
comme anti syndicats voilà c'est de loi
c'était tout d'abord la loi c-300 77 qui
forçait les syndicats a dévoilé
publiquement toute dépense de plus de
5000 $ et tout salaire de plus de 100000
dollars ce qui selon les détracteurs de
cette loi donnait un avantage indû à la
partie patronale l'autre c'était la loi
ses 525 qui changeait des méthodes
d'accréditation syndicale
encore là les détracteurs affirmaient
que cette loi rendrait rendait plus
difficile la syndicalisation des
employés du secteur fédéral ait fallu
faciliter la désagrégation même par un
vote minoritaire donc jeudi le
gouvernement annoncé l'annulation de ces
lois les conservateurs sont évidemment
furieux ses lois distille était
démocratique et répondait à un besoin en
chambre gérard deltell avait ceci à dire
au parti libéral aujourd'hui le parti
libéral on dit merci aux grands patrons
des sinistres pour avoir dépensé des
millions de dollars contre le parti
conservateur c'est ça la réalité c'est
ça la réalité du parti libéral alors
voilà le manuel faudra voir maintenant
quelle sera la stratégie des
conservateurs au sénat feront ils de
l'obstruction pour empêcher l'annulation
de ces lois il faut rappeler que les
conservateurs sont majoritaires au sénat
et pourrait faire pour mettre des bâtons
dans les roues aux libéraux oui nos
collègues de la presse anglophone qui
découvrent monsieur deltell comme un
parlementaire redoutable à vous deux
vous remercie d'avoir été avec nous au
revoir merci
nous sommes en 2015 avait dit juste être
dos lorsque questionné sur la parité au
sein de son conseil des ministres
or le remaniement au québec jeudi
illustre à quel point à bien des égards
la classe politique demeure loin du
compte
certes philippe couillard invité trois
femmes de plus aux cabinets